thanks all for staying under this last
talk for today and this one is about
dichotomies for counting subgraphs and
it's a joint work with Daniel marks so
in this talk will be interested in
accounting subgraphs like these here and
essentially what we want to do is for
each graph say whether the graph is easy
or hard and okay I have to specify bit
what I mean about this so first of all
the problem that will be studying in the
entire remainder of this talk is your
given as input to graphs one of them is
a pattern graph on K vertices the other
graph is a so-called hosts were up on n
vertices and what you're interested in
is the number of sub graphs of G that
are isomorphic to h & x sub graph here I
mean a sub graph that is not necessarily
induced although at the end of the talk
hopefully also have some time to talk
about induced subgraphs but in any case
this is the problem that that we're
studying and you can see that for each
fixed graph this problem is in
polynomial time so the question I
mentioned at the very beginning of the
talk is actually soft and I should have
told you earlier that this would be very
short talk which is of course not true
because the actual problem that we study
is that we fix some Class C and we
restrict our pattern to be chosen from
that class and this gives rise to this
problem counts up C for a fixed class c
where the input is a pattern from your
class which is fixed and you're given a
host graph and you just want to output
this number of sub graphs there of HMG
and then there are of course many
classes that you can look at like click
cycle stars and which of these classes
we ask ourselves which class makes the
problem putting on your time sober ok so
if we study this problem from a
classical point of view then I mean this
answer here can be resolved by
classifying the problems into a
polynomial-time solvable or sharpy heart
and let's say during reductions this is
what you usually gets in a classical
setting so let's try to apply this
classical setting to the sub graph
counting problem that I defined
so again we have this problem for fixed
classes and the question we are asking
is well again which classes make the
problem polynomial-time solvable but now
we have this extra assumption that we
can use that FB is not equal to sharpie
because obviously we have to use some
such so clicks are Sharpie hard just
because deciding clicks is np-hard and
there is a parsimonious reduction
accounting cycle is a Sharpie hard
because you're counting a Newtonian
cycles if you pick the the pattern to
have n vertices then again this is
Sharpie heart but for instance stars
they are easy actually so you get a
polynomial time algorithm which is
actually linear in the size of the host
graph so a star is a vertex that has a
center vertex like this and then k race
and if you want to count the case stars
in a graph G then you can just do this
by summing over all vertices in G and to
each vertex computers binomial
coefficient which is just a degree of
features k because once you fixed a
mapping of the center vertex into your
graph this is just a number of ways you
get to distribute the race among the
neighborhood of me ok so it seems that
assuming FP is not able to Sharpie for
these classes we can get a good picture
what what is easy in what is hard but
unfortunately the January situation is a
bit worse so they are classes for which
we apparently don't get such a
classification so here is a class in
this class 3 which consists of graphs
that are T clicks together with 2 to the
T isolated vertices so they're just
padded click so to say and it's maybe a
weird class but but it exists and we
would still like to say what's going on
there so you can see that the this class
actually and if you want to solve the
sub graph counting problem this graph
you get across a polynomial time
algorithm and just because we're to
count the HT is appearing in G you can
just count the K clicks sorry the T
clicks appearing in G and just
multiplied by this number of ways to to
map the isolated vertices into the
remainder of the graph so all together
you
need to count these T clicks and do this
multiplication so you end up with a
running time of n to the T but t is
logarithmic in the size of the pattern
and the pattern is always bounded by the
size of the host so you really get this
classy polynomial running time but this
is also the best running time we know of
so it doesn't seem that you can solve
this problem in polynomial time and one
problem that we have here is that since
its classic polynomial time we we don't
assume that a Sharpie heart so this
seems to be a candidate for a problem
that the Sharpie intermediate and in
fact if you do a more clever
construction than just picking 2 to the
T isolated vertices but but doing
something along the lines of latin i
still around you can actually get truly
sharpie intermediate classes so ok if we
want to ask if this is the question that
we want to ask then we have a problem
namely sharpie intermediate classes we
won't get a dichotomy but I mean this
kind of gives us a theoretical problem
but from a more practical point of view
there's another problem with this model
namely we cannot do reasonable
statements when the host graph is is
supposedly much larger than the pattern
graph so for each fixed pattern you get
a polynomial time algorithm if the
pattern grows very slowly let's say like
log n you get these classy polynomial
time algorithms again so we don't really
know what's going on there and I would
say that this is this is probably the
most natural model where the sub graph
counting can appear because usually we
have situations where you have a small
pattern which appears in a huge graph
like I don't know you want to count
leaks of size 6 and the facebook graph
so then you can assume that n is huge
and well 6 is not particularly huge so
so to get rid of these two problems we
actually don't study the problem under
FP not equal to sharpie but we pick a
different model to study it and this
model would be that of parameterize
complexity so in parameterize complexity
situation that we have is that we're
looking at parameterize counting
problems so such a problem is just given
some input output some number but now we
have this edition
a parameter couple of X and the
parameter in a problem like this is just
a function that map's inputs to natural
numbers it's supposed to be computable
and the ideas that the parameter
measures some some notion of instance
hardness that is more refined than just
just looking at the instant sighs okay
so there are a lot of examples for
parameterize problems also parameterize
counting problems but let's just use
this this definition to get a
parametrized version of counting sub
graphs so we just take the sub graph
problem for fixed classes again counts
up grass from a class C but now
parametrized by the size of your pattern
so this would be one good example for a
parameterize problem special cases of
this problem would be counting cake
leaks on parameter K counting k cycles
on perimeter k so k clicks is supposed
to mean clicks of size K but there is
also a problem which is not a subgraph
counting problem and that's given a
graph and a number of k which is the
parameter i'll put the number of K
vertex covers in your graph G so if you
look at all these problems then you can
see that you can solve each of these
problems in time n to the K plus some
constant because you can just brute
force of all possible solutions and so
this means that which fixed K you get a
polynomial time algorithm but the task
and parameters complexity is now to drag
this K out of the exponents or to say so
this leads to this notion of fixed
parameter tractability so a problem is
fixed parameter tractable or fpt if you
can solve it in time f of parameter on x
times some polynomial in x where f is
any computable function and a particular
function that may be super polynomial so
well one classical example would be for
instance that this first problem of
counting a vertex covers is actually a
fitty so you can solve it in time 2 to
the K times n meaning you've got to
linear time algorithm for each fixed K
which is of course better than getting
just some polynomial time algorithm for
okay but generally speaking and we would
like to know what happens for these
three problems as well so can we get FPT
algorithm show these problems as well
that's kind of a question that we will
be trying to answer in the remainder of
this talk but to do this we need some
model of hardness for parameterize
problems and that's the that's hardware
we need some complexity theory for
parameterised problems so this leads to
parameterize counting complexity which
was introduced by lumen goya so I should
say that parameterize complexity was
introduced by down Ian fellows like 10
years before that at least 10 years
before that but the counting versions of
these problems were just defined later
so in parameterize counting complexity
again the easy cases which correspond to
polynomial time from our classical
setting our fpt and the hard cases are
sharp w1 heart so sharp w1 heart is the
analog of sharpie hardness so a problem
a sharpie sharp w1 heart if and this is
maybe a bit of a lazy definition but you
can define it that way and it's better
than taking some machine model in my
opinion at least for the purposes of
this talk so one canonical or one
heavily used definition of sharp w1
heart and stress that you can reduce
counting k clicks to your problem in
question by a parameter s reduction so
what does that mean just means that you
have an algorithm that solves the
problem of counting k clicks with an
Oracle for this counting problem sharpie
and the running time of this algorithm
is supposed to be fpt and K so it's
computable function and K times
polynomial in N and the second
restriction that you also need is that
whenever this this algorithm issues the
query to your target problem sharpie
then the query will be bounded by some
so okay the target parameter of your
query
be bounded by some computable function
of the of the source parameter
recollection we have k + kappa where the
words of the roles here okay so k is the
parameter for counting k clicks and
Kappa would be the parameter of your
target problem so to parameterize
problems can have different parameters
and you want to reduce counting k clicks
to counting b and b has this parameter
kappa whereas k clicks as the parameter
K so if you want to solve an instance of
counting k clicks you want to do this by
calling the Oracle only on instances
where this target parameter Kappa is
bounded by function of K that's just the
thing and you need to enforce this
because otherwise you don't get this
which would be closure of fpt under
under FEG reductions and it's of course
something you need to do complexity
theory so in other words just if we if
we now are able to prove that sharpie is
fpt then we also get that cake counting
cake linksys fpt and this is something
that is that is believed to be very
unlikely based on based on the evidence
that the field gives us so yeah that's
parameters counting complexity and if
you apply this now to the problems we
looked at before then I mean we
essentially just defined counting k
clicks to be hard but interestingly you
can also see that counting kate cycles
is also sharp w1 heart so human to our
shoulder and parameterize reduction from
counting k clicks accounting k cycles
and that's interesting because well it
is known that deciding whether your
graph contains the K cycle is actually
fixed parameter tractable by a technique
called color coding so you can solve it
in exponential time in k times
polynomial in n so in a way this is the
comparable to the to the Sharpie
Hutton's result for counting perfect
matchings here we have a give a problem
who's counting version is hard but its
decision version is I mean NP hard but
see
okay and of course for the general sub
graph problem this will have to depend
on the Class C now let's just gather
what we what we learned so far so the
new assumption that we can use now is
assuming that F PT is not equal to sharp
w1 and we're going to ask when is the
supper of counting problem from the
Class C fixed parameter tractable and
keeps the heart cycles our hearts and K
Stars where they stay polynomial time
and what about this pathological class
said that we studied earlier and which
was some kind of counter example in the
classical case so what about these
graphs HT that RT clicks with 2 to the T
isolated vertices they are also sharp w1
heart why because there is I mean the
algorithm I mentioned before that God
that God has class a polynomial time is
actually an FPT reduction you just do
the other way around so if you want to
count k clicks with a reduction by
reduction to counting HK just count HK
in g and divide this binomial
coefficient out and you get a number of
gay clips assuming that n is large
enough but it's ok to assume that and
the running time of this is just the
time you need to to write down the
instance HK and the instance g for
oracle and do this division here and the
target parameter would be the size of
the pattern that you call with but the
size of the pattern is just
exponentially in K so the size of the
pattern is bounded by functional k and
this is an FPT reduction from counting k
clicks to the problem so trapped
everyone heart so it seems hear that
whether we have a ribbon assumption that
allows us to at least get rid of this
one pathological case that I mentioned
earlier so ok let's let's just collect
this so these this particular sharpie
intermediate class that I mentioned
earlier we can handle that we can handle
it in the parameter setting we also get
useful statements when n is much larger
than K because this is what what
parameterize complexity is all about
but we have a new problem and this new
problem is just we actually don't answer
the initial question that that we wanted
to do answer we just look at the
different problem and we'll use
different assumptions and we probably
get a different answer but but for weeds
or maybe reasons that can be considered
weird actually this doesn't apply so
actually if we just ask ourselves this
question we end up with an answer for
the polynomial x of ability of this form
and to elaborate on that I I would
finally have to state this dichotomy
that that I've been teasing you with the
introduction now so finally we can
actually do this thing that I mentioned
in the beginning we can we can try to
state and prove some dichotomies so the
problem that we're looking at is just as
a reminder counting sub graphs from a
class C and what we have to do for this
whole stuff to work is we have to assume
from now on that the classes we are
talking about our recursively enumerable
so that's an assumption that we have to
do for the parameters reductions to work
but let's just say that this is probably
an acceptable condition on a class and
then the dichotomy criterion that we
that we end up with for this for this
situation is we get a dichotomy along
the maximum matching size and the Class
C so the maximum matching size in a
class is just the size of the maximum
matching that you can fit into any graph
of your class C so they're essentially
two situations that can apply you can be
bounded I mean this number can be
bounded by a constant that depends only
on C or its unborn it if you can find
all matching send there so if this
number is bounded by some constant then
it turns out that there is actually a
polynomial time algorithm for counting
stars from the Class C so examples for
such classes would be the class of stars
because you can
only one matchings and stars generally
all classes that that have bounded
vertex cover number actually the classes
that have maximum matching number
bounded by a constant and the class
vertex cover name Abu concert at the
same classes because these two
parameters are just bonded away from
each other by two and and essentially
this algorithm just works by we're
generalizing this idea that that gave
the algorithm for four stars but rather
than just mapping this one Center vertex
interior graph you not have to map the
entire vertex cover into your graph and
do some dynamic programming once this
mapping is fixed but since the vertex
covers have just constant size you can
just brute force all the mappings from
the vertex cover and then you can see
that that you end up with a poem in turn
on the other hand if you don't have a
bound on this maximum matching number
then the problem is sharp w1 heart so so
this situation applies in a minimal case
if the class is that of matchings but it
applies also for paths and cycles
because in both of these graph classes
you can find arbitrarily large matchings
and generally it applies whenever you
can find graphs which you can fit large
matchings and and again let me just
press that in this dichotomy we actually
get the classification when counting
stop graphs is polynomial-time solvable
and the assumptions that we that we have
to make here are that FP t is not equal
to sharp that we want so we assume
something in parameterised complexity
and we get something in classical
complexity again there are sharp
intermediate cases for this problem
so if the the matching size is super
constant but significantly smaller than
K or half of whatever is right if
there's some intermediate complexity and
appearing in the console instead of I am
to the old one it would be something
like n to the size of the matching well
it's it's always n to the vertex cover
allocates end to the two to the size of
the vertex cover essentially so let's
say if you have log log size vertex
covers then you could still get quasi
putting on your time your games yeah
that would still work but then things
become a bit unclean because i really
have to incorporate the actual size of
your vertex cover into it ok so that's
our dichotomy for accounting sub graphs
and there are similar dichotomies so let
me just write this one is in this
particular format here so if you want to
count subgraphs then bounded matchings
makes it makes it easy and otherwise
it's hard if you want to count induced
subgraphs the situation is much worse
for tractability so whenever your class
is finite then you can trivially do this
in polynomial time on the other hand
whenever your class is in finite then it
sharp w1 heart so here for instance
stars were easy but but here they are
not I mean they have their bond
matchings but there is an infinite
number of stars so stars are hard and
things become easier if you go to oma
morphisms so if you want to count
homomorphisms from a class c into host
graphs then by a result of demo and
johnson and this is polynomial-time
solvable if the class has bound the tree
with otherwise it sharp w1 heart and I
will describe later what tree with means
and we get the same situation for
counting colorful swap graphs where your
sub graphs now additionally have colors
on them and you want to respect the
coloring i will also liberate on that
later but again here the criterion is
poetry with and these are these are
weaker conditions on a graph class then
have
bound matchings because for instance
well okay three with is a measure of
three likeness and in particular forest
safety with one but matchings our forest
so matchings are hard here but they are
not hard here and in all of these cases
we have intermediate cases so you know
of these cases you can kind of consider
all these cases are some kind of success
story for fpt where is the shop w 1 this
is chen 30 and where you EGR chen there
are a lot of chance and then okay so
these are dichotomies that that are
obtainable now let's get back to this
sub graph counting problem in the
remainder of the talk I try to sketch
sketch of proof for this and the the
basic outline for the proof is that
first look at the tree both of our class
if the tree with of that class is
unbounded then we can get a reduction
from counting grids that makes the
problem chef w one heart and that's the
relatively often used technique so far
okay I'll elaborate on that later and so
that solves the problem if the trivet of
c is unbounded if the treatment is
founded then the next thing we do is we
look at the matching number if this
matching number is bounded by a constant
then we get these polynomial time
algorithms that i mentioned before if
the number is unbounded then we get a
sharp w1 hardness result by reducing
from counting k metrics so yeah this is
essentially the case distinction that we
have to make to get the dichotomy and I
want to talk first about this and on the
tree with case where we get a reduction
from counting grids so to get the heart
and suz out for counting sub graphs we
actually first look at the problem of
counting colorful sub graphs because it
turns out that the working in this
setting is much easier and we can work
efficiently in this setting above under
the tree with so
and the situation for accounting
colorful subprocess is that we again
have patterns we have a pattern edge on
a host graph G but now both of these
graphs have colorings on them so the
vertices are colored with K colors and a
graph age as additionally this this
restriction that it's coloring must be
by objective so the graph is colorful
and colorings in this setting are not
necessarily proper so what you now want
to look at is the number of color
preserving H copies in G and we denote
this by this number call sup so Callie
preserving H copy ng is just a subgraph
of g that is isomorphic to h by an
isomorphism that map's only vertices
from one color to vertices of that same
color then you can again define a
problem for general classes so given a
class of graph C and the problem would
be on input the colorful graph H from
the classy and the collector of G
parameter size the pattern count these
number of colorful sub graphs of HMG and
this is kind of useful because you can
see that this colorful sub graph problem
can always be reduced to the uncoated
sub graph problem by an application of
the inclusion-exclusion principle so
essentially you get an FPT reduction and
this reduction really needs fpt time we
can get it in the polynomial time
setting you get an FPT reduction from
the colorful problem to the uncut
problem and this is extremely useful
because I ok so at this point I have to
define what tree but actually means but
I won't do it I will instead define what
it means to be to have unbounded tree
with so class is unbounded tree with if
and this is a deep result in graph
structure theorem theory plus C has
unbound the tree with if for every n
there is a graph H in your class such at
the N by M n by n grid is a minor of age
so the greatest justice square grid here
and being a minor
just means that you can get the grid
from H by doing vertex and edge
deletions and edge contractions let's
abbreviate this bulky statement by grids
are minor contained in C and then we
just claim that this uncolored sub graph
counting problem sharp w1 heart we never
see as unbound three with and to do that
let me show that the colorful sub graph
problem on grids a shrub w1 hard this is
not too hard you can you can use a
reduction that is actually a polynomial
time reduction and preserves the
parameter and then the next thing you do
is you show that whenever you have a
class C that contains grids as minors
then counting colorful sub graphs on see
this also sharp w1 heart because there
is an FPT reduction between these two
problems and this holds generally
whenever a classes minor contained in
another class so this problem is so to
say minor monotone complexity wise and
then in this last step we just reduced
the color for the colorful problem to
the uncolored problem and it's really at
this step here that we that we need this
excluded grid theorem because this tells
us exactly that I mean sea has unbound
tree with ok if she has I'm 13 with then
we can find these arbitrarily large
grids in C which this is exactly what
enables this reduction so this is kind
of nice because this is one of these
situations where we can really use this
power of parametrized with options to
invoke some heavy graph theoretic
machinery because for a long time
actually we're ok to get an N times and
grids you would need to get a graph of
exponential size if you either source
brought down to polynomial in the tree
with by now but this doesn't actually
agree the graph Class C could still be
out really sparse but its cursive
innumerable ok so anyway this shows that
counting subgraphs is hard if she has
under the tree with
the next step is we have bounded three
with and we have unbounded matching
number so then the reduction is from
accounting k matchings now first show
that counting k matchings is actually
hard and this is a slide that I've been
using for the past three years now it's
showing a person who try to con three
matchings and and collapsed over the
task because it's hard which is what I'm
going to show so I want to end up from
some shop w one heart problem at this
problem of counting k matchings and this
this initial problem that we're starting
with is counting colorful sub graphs
where the pattern has maximum degree
three so by this classification that I
gave on these previous slides this
problem is shop w one heart and because
if you look for instance that a
hexagonal lattice then you can see that
you can draw a grid on there so the
three with of these lettuces is
unbounded and the program the shop w one
heart and we will use this colorful sub
graph counting problem to counting
colored matchings which are not
necessarily colorful actually colorful
matchings are easy and from these
colored matchings we go to uncolored
matchings again by this inclusion
exclusion principle which we also used
to go from the colorful sub graph
problem to the uncolored one and which i
didn't mention that yeah it's the same
technique so to actually get this
hardens result for colored matchings
this is the initial instance that we
reduce from so we're given these colored
graphs H&G and we're interested in a
number of H copies in G so previously I
wrote called sub for this number now
just where it's up to abbreviate a bit
and what we're going to do now is that
we pick a vertex let's say this vertex V
here and we explode it this way we end
up with a graph H Prime and exploding a
vertex just means that we so this vertex
V has two edges incident with
we replace v by two by two new vertices
which are on the same color and we
redistribute the edges that were
incident with v2 these new new vertices
such that each vertex gets one hatch
then we end up with a new pattern H
Prime and we show that if you can count
h prime copies and graphs then you can
solve this original problem by
constructing two instances g1 and g2
such that you want to count H prime in
g1 and g2 each this gives you two
numbers and some linear combination of
that will give you this original number
that you're interested in so let me
sketch briefly how these instances are
created so if H prime H prime is
obtained by by exploding this yellow
vertex then GI for I equals 1 and 2 is a
graph that you get by just adding i
minus 1 clones for each other vertex and
you can see that if you count H prime in
g1 then you actually just count h prime
of G because GI sorry g1 is just G we
didn't do anything but if you count H
prime in g2 then they're essentially two
things that can happen for 1 h prime
copy so either the two yellow vertices
that you have from this explosion going
to the same block then if you contract
that block or if your contract or blocks
you end up with a copy of HMG and each
copy of H and G can be extended in two
ways to such an H prime copy because you
can take this this way or the other way
where the blue vertex wouldn't appear in
this one would map here or the other
thing that can happen is that these two
yellow vertices hits two different
blocks and then you end up with a copy
of H Prime in G and each copy of H Prime
in G can be extended in four ways to a
copy of H Prime in g2 because at each
block you have two choices and these
choices are independent ok but this is
the number that we want to have and
these are the numbers that we can get by
Oracle course so we have a linear system
of equations that is kind of obviously
invertible and so in other words if we
these numbers then we can cover this
number okay and the very same approach
also works if we explode a vertex of
degree 3 then you just end up with three
new instances so yeah these are the
basic operations that we have and now we
want to combine this to end up in a
reduction from counting colorful
subgraphs to counting color k matchings
so again the initial problem is we have
this pattern h which is colorful it it
is K vertices and edges and its degree
is bounded by 3 we want to count that
pattern appearing in a graph G so the
first thing we do is we explode some
let's say this yellow vertex we get a
copy of H Prime sorry we get a new
pattern graph H Prime and we get two new
host graphs g1 and g2 and we count h
prime copies in g1 and then h prime
copies in g to go to count h prime
copies in g1 we actually construct on a
new graph H prime prime where we explode
this green vertex and we get three new
instances such that this number can be
recovered from these three numbers you
do the same for g2 you can see that if
you do this whole thing k times then you
have exploded all vertices and you end
up with a colored matching because now I
be vertex has degree 1 this colored
matching has L edges and altogether you
have at most 3 to the K graphs so this
is an FPT reduction because it runs in
time at most 3 to the K and the target
parameter if you start it with a graph
on paper gc's you now get a matching on
all edges but L is of K so you have
bound it's the parameter basis so that's
a parameter s reduction from counting
colorful subgraphs to counting colored
matchings and this this second
production again as i mentioned before
is is an application of of simple
techniques like inclusion exclusion
okay so this concludes the hardness
proof okay matchings a sharp w1 hardness
of K matchings now but we now need is it
reduction from counting k matchings to
this general sub graph problem and what
we're using for this is some ramsey
theoretic argument which shows that
whenever you have a graph class that has
bounded tree with but unbounded
matchings then you can actually see that
this class has unbounded induced
matchings this is not particularly hard
to see but the thing is that this this
argument allows us now to classify
hereditary classes quite easily so we
get the dichotomy for hereditary classes
these are classes that are closed under
induced subgraphs and why is that well
just if you look at the tree width and
that's unborn it then we have the sharp
w1 hardness results which I mentioned
before by by this grid tie production
the tree with is bounded and the magic
number is bounded we have polynomial x
of ability the tree with is now under
sorry if the matching number is now
unbounded then this thing here it tells
us that we have unbounded induced
matchings in the class c but since c is
hereditary if you have induced matching
of size K you can just delete everything
that is not part of that induced
matching and you just get this induced
matching which is just contained in C so
you don't you have to do any reduction
your matchings are just contained in the
class so you get you have w1 hardness
here as well and if you want to do this
one non-hereditary classes things become
much more complicated and I would be
happy to talk about this offline but
since i have only think five minutes
left i cannot include this in the talk
so let me compute the talk by showing
some other models for counting subgraphs
they also want to mention so one of
these models that is the despite
interesting also is counting modulo 2 so
the
but recent work that that I'm doing with
her Goodell and Tory was fed so in this
counting modulo 2 business we're looking
at the parity version of the subgraph
counting problem so here we given graph
H from a class and again your host graph
G your parameterize again by the size of
the pattern but now you're just
interested in a number of sub graphs
modulo 2 so one thing that is known is
ok permanence modulo 2 can be solved in
polynomial time so you can count perfect
matchings and bipartite graphs and
polynomial time just because permanence
are determinants modulo 2 and actually
you can generalize this so ok permanence
modulo 2 in polynomial time means that
perfect matchings and bipartite graphs
are easy but actually matchings of
arbitrary size in general graphs are
easy modulo 2 but I I mean you first
have to do interpolation on the matching
polynomially and then to get okay to get
non bipartite graphs you you just have
to do some simple construction but it's
doubling all their gist and observing
that only perfect matching survive this
so in other words the sub graph counting
problem is polynomial-time solvable if c
is a class that contains only matchings
like here but actually and we can
generalize this to show that if you have
a constant C such at every graph in C is
C matching splittable then the sub graph
counting problem modulo 2 is still
pulling on your time and a graph is see
matching splittable if you have some
defect set of style c c is a constant
such as if you remove this set you end
up with a with a matching and this
setting matching is a graph that has
degree at most one so so in other words
if you just take a matching and I mean
we know that matchings are easy and then
adding a constant size set won't make it
harder and on the other hand we can we
can show that if this is not the case
and sees additionally hereditary then
the program is parity p heart but
unfortunately we cannot
yet get rid of this error editorial
restriction and we also don't have the
happen spoof under parity w one so far
so this is kind of recent work and
progress and one interesting thing to
note about this is that this the very
same dichotomy criterion applies for the
decision version of of deciding whether
graph contains a sub graph from a class
so I mean assuming that sees the
hereditary class so Bart Jansen and
Daniel marks have shown that exactly
this this criterion here classifies the
the easy and hard cases for deciding the
existence of a sub graph and in a
certain way this this stuff that we're
doing here kind of indicates that well
counting modulo 2 doesn't seem to be
harder at least in the sub graph
counting model before talking about
polynomial-time solvable ax t on
hereditary classes then deciding so here
we cannot identify new hard cases
okay and then the the other model that I
also want to briefly talk about is when
it was introduced by Mark German kitty
mix and I'm I'm dressed Lee over
simplifying their model to make it kind
of presentable for these slides they
have a much more general model but let's
just say that they're at their model is
counting induced subgraphs fight for a
fixed property file so files just a
function that map's graphs to 0 and 1
for 1 and the input for this problem is
the graph G and the number ok u prime
address by K and the output that you're
interested in is the number of sets x
that have size K and if you if you take
the graph induced by this set X then
this would be a model for the property
so what they showed for instance is that
H is the property of being a sorry if I
is the property of being connected then
you end up with shrapnel you one
hardness the same applies if H is an
even number of edges or an odd number of
edges and you also catch up w 1 hardness
but somewhat more generally they show
that whenever you have a graph class so
whenever you have a property Phi whose
edge density is sub quadratic and then
you also get rap w 1 hardness and the
edge density of a property is defined as
follows so this density of Phi for a
number k is the number of different edge
numbers that you can get by looking at
all k vertex graph that satisfy your
property so for instance if you look at
all graphs then this edge density would
be well it would not be subpar attic but
if you for instance look at the planar
brass then you have a linear upper bound
on the edge density sitting curve and in
other words okay whenever this edge
density is is not quadratic then they
can use some Ramsey theoretic argument
to show that you can identify large
click so large in large independent sets
and then they would use from that to get
hardness or this thing
okay um this concludes my talk thanks
for your attention
if you have something you are producing
classical results from the PT results
that seem to be what you're saying
earlier in oh yeah so the thing is just
that we get a dichotomy we're actually
so we get an FPT wears a sharp w1 how
its dichotomy but the fut cases just
coincidentally turn out to be polynomial
time cases and that's it that's
literally it I mean this just
establishes that if F fitty is not equal
to shop w 1 then these sharp w1 hard
cases they cannot be polynomial time so
that's that's all it happens it's a
magical coincidence that FP tina's
coincides with polynomial time soap
ability but but this applies in many
settings so not just for counting sub
graphs but also for counting yeah
homomorphisms or colorful sub graphs
when you suppose
it also for deciding the yeah deciding
what it works but then it's the trivet
of the course that you have to look at I
and for finding subgraphs we we don't
really know what's going on so we know
that the problem is fpt if you have
boundary with we know that it's
polynomial-time solvable if it's
matching splittable but we have I think
no lower bound at all so in particular
we don't know whether the bomb unborn a
tree with cases rw1 hard so we know that
clicks rw1 hard and actually I think it
it took the field until last year I
think to show that by clicks rw1 heart
and this was a major breakthrough so we
are quite far from classifying the
unbound tree with cases may be there may
be there are things that are somewhere
in this kind of non clear boundary that
I try to draw that actually show that
maybe this is not the right criteria
in a model where you're cutting can do
some girls from property fine so do you
think that the answer is if I is
determined by a set of edges which have
found it vertex culinaire open right and
the rest is to be honest I don't really
know what I don't have too much of an
intuition about the properties setting
it would be reasonable to believe that i
guess but i have no strong reasons to
believe it to be honest other than it
would give a nice clean dichotomy